le timing est quasi simultanés marine le
pen en meeting à reims eric zemmour à
lille mais les deux camps là sur un cela
n'a pas été fait exprès co qu'il en soit
les deux candidats à la présidentielle
dont les idées peuvent paraître
similaires sont en meeting le jour même
et cela intervient alors que marine le
pen a subi quelques défections dans son
camp au profit de celui d'eric zemmour
le polémique qui tient aujourd'hui à
donc son deuxième grand rassemblement
après celui de villepinte qui avait été
marquée par des violences la journée
donc redouté par la police qui craint de
nouveaux débordements à plusieurs
manifestations pour dénoncer la venue
d'eric zemmour à lille aujourd'hui on en
parle avec un autre reporter david
california qui
a bonjour david à leur journée en
redouter par les services de police
qu'en est il exactement
faire bloc les mettra à genoux c'est ce
que vous pouvez lire un sur cette
pancarte juste derrière moi la
manifestation a débuté il y à une
vingtaine de minutes environ plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont réunies
afin de dénoncer la venue d'eric zemmour
ici lui faire comprendre qu'il n'y ait
pas est le bienvenu au sein de la ville
de lille dénoncer son discours haineux
et raciste c'est également l'objectif 1
des centaines de personnes venues se
rassembler ici un important dispositif
de sécurité a été mis en place le
cortège est en tout cas encadré par
plusieurs par plusieurs camions de
gendarmes et de policiers des cannois où
ont été disposées également un peu plus
loin du cortège de manifestants pour
rappel le meeting et d'eric zemmour se
tiendra à à 15 heures au grand palais le
grand palais qui se trouve à une
centaine de mètres du ce de ce
rassemblement un premier rassemblement
avait lieu ce matin à l'initiative de
martine aubry et du président de sos
racisme
le porte parole de la jeune garde anti
fascistes de lille a tenu à montrer à sa
tête pour montrer pour montrer qu'ils
sont solidaires avec ce mouvement faire
bloc contre l'extrême-droite vallée à
l'idée principale de cette journée je
vous propose de l'écouter nous on a
décidé de voilà pas être organisateur de
ce rassemblement parce que voilà cessé d
organisation beaucoup plus
institutionnels etc avec lesquels on
peut travailler occasionnellement mais
ce n'est pas notre mode d'action des
organisations de jeunesse on essaye
voilà de faire des cortèges dynamique
notamment dans les manifestations etc
c'est ça qu'on appelle à la
manifestation de l'après midi par contre
il était important de montrer nos têtes
aussi pour dire que voilà il ya des
liens de solidarité qui doivent se faire
s'ils ont toujours existé à gauche face
à l'extrême droite il était bon de
rappeler que ouais l'ennemi il est bien
trop grand pour pour rester chacun dans
notre coin
quelques échauffourées à noter en début
de manifestation une arrestation a eu
lieu d'un militant anti fasciste qui a
provoqué la colère des manifestants des
affrontements ont eu lieu dès tirs de
gaz lacrymogènes se sont produits en de
la part des forces de l'ordre qui
avaient protesté contre cette
arrestation mais pour le moment aucune
autre violence a dénoté a noté ce matin
donc je vous le disais le rassemblement
de martine aubry et du président de sos
racisme montré qu'ils règlement ne fait
pas partie de l'adn de la ville c'était
tout l'objectif dénoncer son discours
haineux qui va à l'encontre des valeurs
de la république et de la démocratie
c'est tout l'objectif de martine aubry
la maire socialiste qui a répondu à nos
trois micros ce matin je pense que il ya
seulement dix ans on aurait été dans la
rue à chacun de ces propos à la et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut redire à la
france que c'est pas la france discours
là et que nous c'est pas notre france en
tout cas et que ce que nous défendons va
à l'encontre complet de ce qu'il raconte
voilà alors après ça je vous renvoie la
balle c'est à vous votre responsabilité
journalistes de vous poser la question
moi je ne porte pas d'atteinte je
considère qu'aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle est largement due au
fait que les politiques ne font plus de
politique de vraies politiques
unir ses forces pour faire un blog
contre l'extrême droite et le racisme
c'est l'idée principale cet après midi à
lille pour lé nombreux rassemblements
qui a lieu à nous sommes à une heure
maintenant du début du meeting des
d'eric zemmour un climat hostile pour le
candidat à l'élection présidentielle son
deuxième grand meeting depuis ville pas
tout on se souvient qu'il y avait eu
également des échauffourées à des
violences en tout cas tout a été mise en
place au sein à de la ville de lille
pour éviter ces nouvelles violences le
cortège que vous voyez derrière moi va
partir pour se rendre place de la
république où avaient lieu également ce
matin la mobilisation de martine aubry
et du président de sos racisme
encadrés par un dispositif de sécurité
assez conséquent pour se rendre au grand
palais l'artillerie lourde a été sortie
par la ville de lille énorme dispositif
afin de pouvoir éviter ces nouvelles
scènes de violence sont qu'on avait pu
voir lors du meeting d'eric zemmour à
villepinte vous l'aurez compris en tout
cas il n'est pas le bienvenu ici